Hey Youtubers it's Charlie so today's going
to be all killer frost everybody dust off
your winter is coming puns because we are
probably going to see her on the flash season
two there are actually four different versions
of her character in the comics but the important
one is Caitlin snow the most recent version
because she's been played by the very wonderful
Danielle Panabaker on the flash and new round
of the DC giveaway starts now all you to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video special giveaway whenever we
get the comic on so just careful for spoilers
for the flash season one if you if you haven't
seen the finale yet because I'll I'll be talking
about Caitlin snow killer frost we got a teaser
for and that finale in that there were a lot
of questions as to what that meant what Barry
was seeing he was traveling along his own
timeline so that was presumably something
from the future the way the reverse flash
explained it Barry was seeing offense across
all points of his timeline but that the current
timeline so the way I see it or current version
of Caitlin is going to become killer frosts
in the future unless team flash tries to do
something crazy to change the future that
would create a new timeline but remember the
reverse flash said that when you try and do
that when you try to change the future to
avoid some a big catastrophic event time will
find a way to replace that was something just
as bad yes is to consider that the writers
on the flash probably wouldn't tease us was
something like Danielle Panabaker killer frost
if they never intended to deliver it so let's
is a otherwise a Comic con next week plan
on killer frost at some point in season two
the real question is why what is super nice
karaoke best friend Caitlin turn into killer
frost we know she's a metahumans but the way
she looks now in the way she looked in that
vision Erdrich are dramatically different
like she had super blonde hair her version
of the character is the fourth killer frost
she's like the new 52 killer frosts although
technically there were two killer frosts that
appear during the new 52 DC just rebooted
their entire line so we don't know what's
can happen with killer frost going forward
but presumably they let Caitlin snow keep
on being killer frost because DC and Marvel
have both started to make the comics look
a little bit more like the movies in the TV
shows that they do Felicity smoke is a really
good example of that in the the green arrow
comics Felicity actually started out a long
time ago during the firestorm comics as the
stepmom of Ronnie Raymond cut to right now
in the comics unit because the popularity
of the character on Arrow it started to make
her look more like the TV show version of
the character so yay for Emily better cards
maybe they'll do the same thing with Danielle
Panabaker will see you can see like DC's thought
process where it's like millions of people
see a certain version of a character on TV
and their thinking will hate you know maybe
they want to read more stories with this character
so let's make comic books that reflect that
is true for both Marvel and DC picked up the
films in the TV shows drive up comic book
sales big time the original version of the
character Comic has a funny story especially
when you think about it in the context of
the TV show characters the very first version
of the character was named Crystal frost she
started out in firestorm number three she
was one a Martin Stein student she fell in
love with them but because he wasn't the the
pervy kind of college professor he turned
her down she got super pest locked herself
in the chamber and you wind up with a pretty
standard science experiment gone wrong origin
story she came out of the special chamber
with I space powers her motivation as a villain
became attacking men like she hated men she
literally had a frozen heart see get the metaphor
Martin Stein turned her are to ice and then
it literally turned to ice the reason she
started attacking firestorm was because Martin
Stein was one half of firestorm she ended
up dying whenever she absorbed too much of
his heat energy though she was resurrected
as a black lantern during blackest night you
really got a watch out how you treat those
ex-girlfriend because they might come back
as super zombies so the next killer frost
was Louise Lincoln she debuted in firestorm
volume 2 number 21 but she didn't become killer
frosts until about 13 issues later she was
actually like a best friend and colleague
of Crystal frost she idolized her so much
that she tried to re-create the accident the
gave for the killer frost powers it words
and she started trying to get revenge on firestorm
for crystals that mosey will probably know
this version of the character as the suicide
squad version you can also call the sexy version
of the character they gave her like giant
boobs that is they softened all her features
they made her more attractive this version
of the character is the one that they used
during the assault on Arkham animated movie
last year if you haven't seen that you should
check it out I means it's a good movie all
by itself she even became part of this frozen
villain team up your DC has a lot of like
I space villains so guerrilla Grodd in the
in this instance where he was attacking much
as superheroes mind controls Mr. freeze icicle
Captain cold and killer frosts to team up
against superheroes she even fought all her
Queen in green arrow volume 3 number 55 that
was about 10 years ago but it was before the
new 52 reboot he defeated her by shooting
her with the Greek fire arrow which we have
not seen on the TV show yet that be pretty
bad ass for those he that don't know what
Greek fire is it's a lot like a wildfire on
game of thrones you you can't put it out with
water either to smother it or cut it's oxygen
supply off after the new 52 reboot Lauren
frontier became the new killer frost for for
a brief period she debuted whenever the new
firestorm kicked off of firestorm version
for that was when they change the way firestorms
powers work and Jason rusch and Ronnie Raymond
both are able to become firestorm on their
own so she attacks them they fuse to make
a single firestorm in the reaction that that
causes takes her down a little while after
that and in 2013 a couple years later but
still during the new 52 they introduced the
Caitlin snow killer frost her origin story
is kind of a twist on the first two versions
the characters origin stories that that chemical
reaction like that that science experiment
accident the twist is is that the accident
was caused by hive agents which is in a facility
investigating this this device hive agents
of infiltrated she has trapped goes through
the reaction and comes out with killer frost
powers the difference this time is is that
she's more like a heat vampire that that's
her motivation whenever she absorbs heat it
it makes her look more humanlike it slowly
returns her to a a more normal state that
you is constantly seeking heat sources to
absorb the reason she goes after firestorm
is because he's like an unlimited source of
heat so she's not she's not in love with him
like Caitlin on the TV show is you can see
how that the TV show version of the character
is kind of a blend of all these different
killer frost characters we can only guess
as to why she might turn against team flash
and why her appearance would change what she
get that light colored hair but just expect
the writers to pull things from her comic
book history to incorporate into the TV show
it's the same way that Barry Allen on the
TV show is kind of a combination of Wally
West in the comics and baryon in the comics
like is that her powers are are pretty similar
to a lot of the other I space villains like
she just has like standard I space attacks
but the newer versions of the character can
absorb heat she's also been able to mine control
people by kissing them if you wondering what
she might look like on the TV show they just
think of of what Captain cold would look like
if he didn't need the gun so my big question
for you guys on a TV show what you think is
going to happen to turn Caitlin snow into
full-blown killer frost we just learned in
the finale that she and Cisco are both metahumans
so she probably doesn't know that she has
powers yet because Cisco did know he had powers
what they might do is choose to honor the
original version of the character and make
her turn cold metaphorically because of something
with Ronnie Raymond they just got married
she super in love with them remember how she
got when she thought he was still dead so
if you are sidelined or something happen to
them something terrible that might push her
over the edge she knows that Barry can go
back in time so if she were to ask Barry hey
can you go back in time change the past so
that this does not happen to Ronnie and he
refuses that that might be something to create
a huge rift between them because even if she
does get powers that doesn't explain why she
would turn against team flash and no matter
what she ends up doing don't think of her
is an out right villain like even Captain
cold is in and out right villain he's more
of an antagonist who is going to be an antihero
during legends of tomorrow not quite good
but not quite bad for those asking about Comic
con though we it would actually have a little
bit of information about what's going on with
all the DC TV shows they're doing the big
DC super panel like they did last year but
though mostly be there to show off new stuff
for legends of tomorrow and Supergirl but
that but they will have like arrow in flash
stuff they haven't started shooting the new
seasons yet so it's not like they have big
trailers to show off but Stephen a Mel did
promise that they would be bringing something
special the only way I be allowed to post
footage would be if DC says it's okay but
you see that they're really good about posting
that stuff online so I'm not too worried about
that so in addition to posting the panel stuff
I should be able to post the new the
new footage to haven't completely worked out
my schedule yet but later this week him to
start doing specific Comic con previews that
all say you know what the schedule is going
to be when I'm in a post videos what's can
be happening so be sure to subscribe to get
everything is going to be crazy Comic con
will be a little bit more laid-back this year
but those still be at least like 10 or 14
videos that I'll be posting I'll explain that stuff
a little bit better in the Comic con previews
so look out for those starting like Thursday
or Friday I will leave you with this one teaser
for the flash season two Grant Gustin said
that we would learn who the villain is right
away and it would be a crossover villain with
legends of tomorrow so Vandal Savage might
also be the big bad on flash season two everybody
just explode about that in the comments just
in case you just didn't see it I posted video
last week explaining what's going on with
the flash season two premier and arrow season
for the click here to learn all about that
and can click here to learn all about the
multi-verse on the flash thank you so much
for watching everybody, let's high five and
I'll see guys tomorrow!